[Music]
so this example has some serious effects
for production-sized apps where you have
authentication or things that testing
should not be
confirming
one of the difficulties when doing
production-sized apps and you're running
it through unit tests is
interacting with outside sources this
can be authentication this can be
database requests
and one of the things that we recommend
you do is you listen to a
flag or a global option
of
shiny.test mode and if shiny.test mode
is true
i recommend having a different ui or
server or reactive behavior given this
flag
and you can have things like the
authentication isn't even uh addressed
if i do a uh you know a restricted
database call maybe instead i load a csv
of information you know one we're not
testing the database we're actually just
testing the shiny app so we need to try
to isolate our tests to what we can
control
and using this flag we can turn it on
turn that behavior on or turn it off and
i think it's just really great as to how
to you can override your app's default
behavior
so
let's look at the app that we've been
doing in the past two videos where we
ask our name and it'll tell us the first
part
uh
our first letter of our name and then
let's just add in a third field of
penguins and
so it lighten the mood a little bit
we're going to say
how many penguins are going to be coming
for dinner
and
so let's just add this into our app and
we have it here i'm just going to run it
for demonstration purposes and i click
greet i said hello barrett first letter
name is b and there are 333 penguins
coming for dinner
and this is fun uh but like if i keep
hitting gree
if we kind of look as to where this
penguin count is coming from it's coming
from this authenticated database request
or something that i'm going to have
returned random data
and so if i click read again that's 330
324
336 this is not deterministic at all and
this is therefore not useful for testing
because if you keep running this test
over and over it will fail there will be
no way for it to be correct
because the data changes underneath
so instead we can listen
to
our
flag
so i'm going to change just wrap this
one part
and say if
we'll get an option of shiny dot test
mode and if we'll default this value to
false but if it's true then i want to
return a test
database request so this is something
that returns static data and will only
retrieve um like what i want it to have
otherwise if i'm not in test mode then
let's just do the authenticated database
request
this will be stored into penguin data
and then the penguin data will will
count the number of rows and then
hopefully we have a consistent count
now if i just run my app in reload app
this is not in testing mode so we should
still see our original behavior so i see
barrett we see greet it's something like
333 321 you know different amount of
each time when i click greet
but
let's run this uh just kind of looking
at our uh
[Music]
application here so if i run this with
the app
and i call app dollar view
so that i have it
it opens up in the chrome uh chromium
based browser and i have what's your
name we call set input ferrite we call
appgree we can see that updated and here
it says hello first letter name is b and
there are 68 penguins coming for dinner
it's a funny phrase but it's 68 it's not
300 and so if i click greet again and
again and again and again
68 is now constant and it's still going
to stay there
[Music]
if i look at the values to see what we
have app dollar get values
i have output penguins there are 38
penguins coming for dinner i could
actually update that so that we have
another exported test value of the
penguin count
so if i update with penguin count
say
penguin
count equals a reactive expression where
i export that penguin count
save it
and then i have to i'm going to stop
this app here
and then i'm just going to restart those
interactive tests
where i run app and i click greet
and let's view it now i don't need to
necessarily open up the viewer at the
beginning it's usually useful when
debugging errors but it still says 68
and at dollar get value of export equals
penguin count
is 68.
perfect so now we can make assertions on
this value and it'll be consistent every
single time
this is just so useful for getting
around those database calls that take
like 5-10 minutes to execute you know
like or you're you're asking a different
api about something that is outside the
control of shiny we want these unit
tests to be consistent and fast that way
you want to do them and you want to do
them often
[Music]
you